[Music]
today's question comes from john in
indianapolis i have a high stress job
that pays 230 000 a year in addition to
dealing with aging parents teenagers in
the pandemic the job is wearing me out
and it's having a negative impact on my
life i've been offered a new job where
i'd take a 30 to 40 000 year pay cut
with the same company but the work is
invigorating and entrepreneurial i'm
having trouble justifying this pay
decrease although i feel i'm going to be
happier our only debt is our mortgage
college is funded my wife earns a great
salary and we have a healthy savings
account so why am i struggling with this
decision i don't want to be one of those
unhappy people saddle with a job they
don't like yet they stay for the money
well
john then don't be one of those people
you don't want to be one of those people
so uh my mentor this guy to the left of
me
he's got a great little tactic when he
gives a speech and he's talking about
money changing you go just aside just a
little quick clap and i think john you
don't want to be one of those unhappy
people that stay just for the money let
me help you a little bit you don't need
the money a 30 to 40 000 pay cut right
now
uh for you is going to take you just
below 200 000 a year and your wife makes
a great salary we don't even know that
number so you guys may be in that 300
000 range you're above 250.
this work is clearly having a tremendous
impact on you all of the signs are there
you need to give yourself permission to
do the right thing and this is the right
thing i will also tell you that this new
job being invigorating and
entrepreneurial tells me two things that
there's probably a path back up to the
money you're making now if not going
beyond that i don't have uh that
information in front of me but this is
the right move you don't need to feel
bad about it you're not doing the wrong
thing you know dave it reminds me you
know we heard our last the debt-free
screamer talk about deep programming
and this is an issue here where we are
so
programmed in our world to put
significance
and success completely in the financial
bucket and yet that's just simply not
the case and it makes people like john
feel like if i take a strategic cut
that i can absolutely absorb that
somehow i'm doing the wrong thing or
it's a dumb thing or a not smart thing
and i think that's real but in this case
john this is the right move all the way
around
i don't think it's dumb and i agree with
ken i would take it
however i think you need to keep in mind
that the aging parents and the teenagers
are still going to be there
so where's your stress really coming
from
what's really going on
i mean if you've got some family stuff
that's out of balance and you need to
set some boundaries have you got some
tough decisions you've been unwilling to
make
uh with either one of those other two
subjects
that are putting that are the real cause
of the stress make real sure you're
treating the right problem
not the symptom
and the second thing is this again i'll
agree with kent take the job john
however i do not agree
with the supposition that the only way
you find happiness is to move down an
income
that you can't find something that's
invigorating what was the phrase he used
an entrepreneurial that pays 300 000 a
year
why is it we always think to be happy we
have to make less money what is this
stupid thing that's floating around in
this culture that says that
by the way if you do something you love
you're better at it and you should make
more money
ultimately yeah i mean but this idea
that you have to have poverty associated
with happiness or less money associated
with happiness is absurd so i would
choose a third option as a consideration
and that is where can i find something
invigorating entrepreneurial that pays
300.
oh
why is it we have to go down all the
time i don't understand this so anyway
it's okay if you do and i'm going with
ken's recommendation but i'm going to
challenge you on those two points make
sure you got the parents and the
teenager thing working because dude
that's still going to be there yep and
you got to be careful what you think the
stress is so you know the first time
that happened to me
is when i filed bankruptcy
the bankruptcy attorney
um
didn't do a lot of things right but he
said one really wise thing
he said uh because you're you're under
this tremendous weight
of debt which feels like he feels right
you got this overwhelming anxiety over
the top of you and where you're like
something's standing on your chest i
can't breathe and then the day you file
bankruptcy that that's just poof you
know most of it anyway is gone right and
you got some more stress points but by
and large i've been fighting it for two
and a half years i was ready to sit down
the rock baby yeah okay but that guy
looks at me and he goes you know what
filing bankruptcy does not create an
income
yeah mic drop yeah that's right it's
really good you know it's like you know
you're not going to prosper
because you filed bankruptcy you've
still got to go out there to kill it and
drag it home whatever it is you still
got to find a way to eat
and of course i respond i got this
figured out but but i mean it's still i
can remember that 30 years ago i
remember that conversation right now
and so that's what i always think you
know be careful what you wish for
because it might may not be touching
what you're talking about you're still
the common denominator you're still
going to be in the next marriage you're
still going to be in the next job your
parents and your teens are still going
to be there after you make this move
you're the common denominator follows
you everywhere i'm glad you brought that
up because
he could take this move and it could be
on paper all the things that he says it
is but if the personal life is burning
the job doesn't solve that right it will
help right in some ways you've got some
purpose as you move into the office but
if it's 70 job stress and 30 family
it'll help it'll help if it's the other
way around it's not going to make a
difference you're just going to make
less money
exactly right and i think that was a
really great call out here and i would
also agree with you in this situation if
that's the only thing that you've got
but it's rarely the only thing and this
is situation well i've got an
opportunity here
and it's going to be better in all these
ways and it's less money and i think
you're right you got to consider the
whole field the whole universe of jobs